en avion a atterri ce matin le journal
le soir aussi jeté un seau d'eau quand
tu pars du principe qu'un briquet bic et
1,6 point c'est pas le même bruit tu
peux imaginer tout ce que je peux voir
dans mes affaires et pas dans le sable
ça fait pas de bruit donc nous on refait
tu es pas on est des gros tricheurs
enfin créer des bruits là où en principe
est exactement
exactement c'est ça on fait des portes
les attaques même s'il n'ya pas une
porte au fond peut la faire et ça c'est
cette taille de patrick qui joue avec
des micros différents qui qui permet de
faire des reliefs quoi on crée du relief
on fait un tiramisu de son on rajoute
des présences des pas des effets et de
tous fait une couche sonore plus le
monteur son et la musique une boîte
d'allumettes pour une boîte d'allumettes
à sa gamme hp c'est calme à
l'interrupteur dupont tuera de
l'interrupteur et pour faire des
crissements de voiture je fais d'autres
trucs tu as parlé avec un nom comme ça
tu arrives à a donné du relief et une
voiture qui passe tu vois
c'est un peu le système dé quoi toi je
me crée des parquets j'ai vu et à pic à
20 ans qui me suivent parce que j'étais
besoin de tapis j'ai tatchou sur
différents jeux sur qui me sert beaucoup
si une joueuse turquie magie chaussures
pour ger depardieu tu vois des grosses
chaussures comme ça qui permet de donner
du poids aux personnages c'était les
chaussures de départ entre autres je
m'en sers dans les films mais pourrait
donner du poids parce que c'est un
garçon pas c'est assez pesant à l'image
est bonne note du poids ça lui donne de
la crédibilité au niveau du son je vais
faire une femme en chaussures compensées
donc genre de chaussures et j'ai chargé
surtout de manière de faire j'ai fait un
truc un peu plus féminin et moi agressif
quoi tu vois pas ce que les leçons et
les démarches sont différentes
évidemment a complètement et c'est un
petit garçon comme on a fait aux
taulards et youssef si c'est un petit
garçon une petite fille un gros une
fille qui marche un peu énervé tu vois
c'est un instrument de musique une
chaussure à talon
c'est une femme qui est énervé équidés
cela on arrive à jouer d acoustique
craint qu'avec une chaussure certes la
fille elle marche l'appui à une marche
elle marche à plat il va monter un
escalier mais elle oublie quelque chose
à redescend tu joues faut être un peu
danseurs ici on fait que les extérieurs
on fait tous des extérieurs avec deux
tonnes de soles des graviers de l'herbe
d'état dans un arrêt d'arbres avec tous
les extérieurs bon ton de l'eau pour
faire de l'eau pour faire la mer donc en
fin de compte tutoyer 7,5 avec une
petite surface de dos comme sa taille va
faire des vagues
les gros plans de la mer c'est pour
donner du relief quoi on fait pas la
mère entièrement mais tu fais vraiment
des gars me trouver et carbone
aujourd'hui sont arrivés à tout faire
patrick je fais quoi là
d'accord d'accord
patrick qui est mon âge et son et ami
depuis plus de 25 ans 27 ans qui était
la console qui étaient là aux commandes
de tout ce qui est prise de son c'est
lui qui m'en registre un bruiteur sans
argent nous on sait rien écoute on va le
faire ma main sur la première partie je
suis ce parti j'aime bien provisions je
n'aime pas le côté préparée gmail côté
un peu sur le sur le fil du rasoir
on a aussi une petite voiture et nous
permettent de faire de la permettre de
faire de la postsynchro et du bruitage
donc pour faire des voix et en même
temps du bruitage pour les films
l'actrice principale est que toutes
sortes de sol toutes sortes de portes
différentes parce que tu as les portant
de l'année des portes en bois des portes
en verre chaque porte les couleurs de
sons des portes sont différents et la
troisième pièce qu'on a ici c'est la
cuisine
c'est un petit appartement là on a toute
la partie cuisine avec four frigidaire
toutes sortes de vins qui nous permet de
faire des bruitages différent car si tu
parles d'une base à lévis en céramique
fait pas le même rôle qu'un hiver métal
quand l'eau coule dans un évier en
céramique et un boîtier rond et 6 et un
évier en métal basse et plus forts pour
ça c'est un peu comme un orchestre
philharmonique c'est partout il ya des
matières sont différentes du verre un
verre à pied fait pas de bruit qu'une
jeune chef de bière
j'étais un peu feignant à l'école et en
fin de compte j'ai suivi mon père un
jour et son assistant parti en retraite
et il m'a dit bah écoute si tu veux
viens me voir au début je suis allé je
faisait flipper le dauphin j'étais par
terre une bassine je faisais la queue
dauphin j'étais content parce que je
voyais les délais film avant qu'il passe
à la télévision
donc j'en parlais aux copains puis ça
m'a appris ça m'a plu j'ai bossé pendant
10 ans inclus
il n'y a pas de formation c'est père en
fils ou avant c'était de copains copains
ou alors nageurs du son père showman qui
lui demande de faire une porte un pas
puis tout d'un coup il se met à faire le
broutage toi laisse mes toilettes pour
les toits alors qu'ils courent non tu
sais encore rien aux milles vers
l'animal voir si tu arrives pas tu fais
ça depuis s'est fait frapper des deux
pieds des petites filles c'est parti 90
je considère comme un comédien comme un
bricoleur comme pour eux pour comédiens
bricolant afin bricoleur macgyver
comment dire un peu un peu de tout quoi
de plus de bricoler voilà on est dix
artistes ou est pourquoi tour mais on
est plutôt flatteur de son quoi je
m'amuse toujours même en baissant 12 14
heures par jour en studio et je m'amuse
toujours